All right. So this is my talk called
Agents of Robots 2. I've given different
variants of this talk in person for
different events, but this is the first
one that I've done for coding agents.
So to kick things off, um just a little
bit about me. I've been a lifelong ML
engineer and I've worked at places like
YouTube and Google where I worked on the
two tower embedding model as well as
some early work on BERT and mixture of
experts.
I worked on ML and robotics at Whimo
where a lot of my focus was on the data
side as well as reward modeling and
evaluation.
And most recently, I've been working on
a company called Abundant, where we work
on a lot of the same concepts applied to
data sets for Foundation Model Labs and
their training for agentic coding
models.
Um, none of this will cover any inside
information about Whimo, but we'll
instead cover some general topics that
are carried over from self-driving and
robotics into digital agents.
So I'll kick things off in kind of like
talking about what some of the parallels
are. And I think one of the main things
is that you sort of have this 1% versus
99% problem where you think that the
model is doing most of the work. But
when you get into real world
applications, the model is only doing 1%
of the work and 99% of the work goes
into other things. So in robotics you
have the hardware and sensors and
actuators you have integration
deployment and you have this whole
offline stack that does simulation
training um and other things. In agents
you also have this. So if we take a look
at the two stacks
um so in in robotics you have hardware
and you have actuators you have the
fleet and in agents you also have um
sort of like a body right whereas
robotics is you know very obviously
embodied because you go from a brain to
a physical body. In agents you go from a
model to sort of a body of a digital
robot that includes tools. So now we
have APIs and MCPs as well as more
advanced uh embodiment in terms of the
terminal and the browser and the VM. So
you're starting to see like the robots
hands and arms and legs to even more
advanced things like the entire OS and
persistent file systems and things like
that. Um in addition you have the
offline stacked so transfer over. So
we're not just finished when we have the
model. We also have to continuously
retrain. We have to monitor these
things. We also have human feedback
loops and all this other stuff that we
have to build as far as the tooling to
even support development of the agent.
And that's like sort of one of the first
learnings that I I want to share is that
um often times in self-driving people
would often talk about the winning team
not just having the best model and the
best online stack but having the best
offline stack because that enables
developers to be much faster and ship
more much more reliably.
So moving on, there's this concept I
want to share in robotics of open loop
and closed loop. This is very simply uh
being able to take an action or to uh
move an actuator or a motor and then
being able to get the feedback of how
that actually uh happened in the real
world so that you can close the loop on
that actual action. So, for example, if
I turn the wheel left, I want to
actually measure uh how much did my car
actually turn so that I can recalibrate
and make sure that I'm turning exactly
the amount I intended to because these
things aren't perfect.
In the same way, we're starting to see
where some openloop things actually need
to be closed. So, for example, if I run
a bash command and I run an open-ended
process, well, sometimes I can't observe
the outputs, at least not in real time.
I can't measure whether that bash
command completed and I can't exit early
if I need to. So that that's an example
of where we need to make things more
closed loop.
Another thing that's kind of nuanced is
the fact that um we are implicitly
discretizing in time. So what do I mean
by that? There are explicit design
choices that we need to make in robotics
about the input space and then the
action space. And particularly in the
input space, you have different
modalities. So you have the option to
use vision, LAR, radar, all these
different inputs and then combine them
in different ways to get a sense for the
world. You also have the ability to
discretize the world in different ways.
You can sample things every second. You
can sample things only when they're
pushed to you. Or you can sample things
in this example on like 50 Hz, so 50
times per second.
So that means I'll keep updating the
state of the world and I'll keep
replanning uh and I'll react to the
world very quickly. However, in agents
we've kind of done this implicitly. So
in agents we often have a conversation.
So we wait to take our turn. We execute
a tool, wait for the entire response.
Maybe we do that in sort of weird ways,
but we don't do this thing that's
natural robotics where we keep sampling
from the world and we keep interacting
in real time. So this is an implicit
design decision that is made that has
its pros and cons. The pros are it's
very easy to reason about when we have
turns. It's very easy to reason about a
conversation. It's really easy to reason
about an input and output of a turn. Um
but in in uh but the downside of that is
that we don't get to do things in real
time. You can't immediately respond to a
pop-up. We can't immediately interact
with a longunning process. So these are
the implications of the design decisions
that we make.
So more on those uh inputs and action
spaces. So in inputs we actually have
handcrafted a bunch of tools, a bunch of
ways that we can stream from tools, we
can stream from the user, but there are
other options out there. So one example
I want to highlight is the terminus
agent from terminal bench. Um, so this
is very very awesome and unique in that
they're actually using a T-X stream. So
you can actually do character by
character uh input and output if you
want to where you can do things like
control C or you can do various window
commands if you want to. Um, and so that
that's a very unique and more flexible
way of interacting with our action space
that we don't traditionally think about
when designing agents.
Other ways in which you could do action
space and robotics. We could plan in
purely XY. So you move up one block and
then move over by two. You can do that
in coarse ways. You can do that in
continuous space. You can do things in
2D. You can do things in 3D. You can do
things in acceleration instead of just
position. You can do things in
velocities. Um in agents we should also
think about this although it's less
relevant. You can you don't have to
think about just interacting with uh
MCPS and tool calls. Like I mentioned
with Terminus, you can interact with the
computer at a character level. You can
even do things like the dreamer paper
where you interact with the computer
purely by interacting at 20 frames per
second with the mouse clicks and
keyboard. So the question is what
trade-offs are we making and what
implicit or explicit design decisions
have we made that either enable us to do
more or is limiting what we can do with
our agent.
The next thing I want to talk about is
how we're going from stateless processes
to stateful processes. If you think
about driving in a video game, you can
spawn from nothing. And you don't have
to worry about where I came from and
where I go after I terminate the
session. You just have to worry about
what I do during that session. But
that's obviously not true in the real
world. In the real world, you have a
real car. That car takes up mass. It
takes up space. And so, you do have to
worry about where that car ends up. And
you have to worry about how we got into
the scene, right? everything is moving.
There are implications to how fast
you're moving and how fast everyone else
is moving. Similarly, we're going from
these stateless agents to more stateful
agents. Right? Before we just had to
spin up a session and the session, get
an artifact out of it. That's great.
Now, we have VMs. VMs that are stateful
both in terms of what's running, but
also the persistent file store. And so,
now when we have agents and we spin them
up, we have to consider, hey, what is
the entire space that we're running
into? What are all the Slack messages
that are currently going on? What is the
state of the world? What are all of the
things that I have to interact with? And
not only how we do that, deal with that
online, but how does that impact how we
do evaluation and simulation? So these
are this is one of the more interesting
things that's happening in agent space
right now.
One of the more nuanced things more
familiar to the people that are working
on modeling and training is a sort of
like dagger and out of distribution
problem. So just like in robotics and
agents, we have options of training our
models with imitation uh imitation
learning being similar to the SFT from
human demonstrations versus RL. And RL
can be in simulation or it can be in
other ways as well. But one of the known
issues with imitation is that as soon as
you get a little bit out of distribution
or off policy in relation to the human
examples, you get really out of
distribution. And you can start to see
this in agents such as browser agents.
When you see a pop-up that never
happened in training because humans
actually interact with pop-ups quite
naturally, it gets confused and it gets
really confused. So this is an issue of
cascading issues that you can see has
been studied for quite a while in
robotics.
And the general theme around this is
that actions have consequences. We're
not just dealing with classification
models. We're not just dealing with
prediction models or sequences. We're
dealing with a whole new paradigm in
which you predict, you act, and then you
deal with the consequences of that
action and then re-evaluate everything
you've done before. And that's really
tough because actions have consequences
and actions have consequences in a very
messy real world.
And as a result of the complexity of the
real world, that's where simulation
comes into play such that you can
represent all of these complexities and
all the messiness of the real world into
your starting state and you can play
through uh the real world not just in a
single path but all the paths that you
could possibly take as your agent
changes. So we call that playing out
counterfactuals.
The other thing to be aware about, and
this is sort of like classic
reinforcement learning or robotics, is
the concept of an MDP. And so that's
where there's an agent that takes into
account a state and a reward and then
we'll take actions on an environment or
a world. And this is just sort of a
formalism about how to conceptualize how
you're running the agent loop. And these
are just useful primitives to have on
hand so that you can describe and you
can communicate what's going on.
The reason this is important is because
we're moving from just plain chat models
to agent models that take action. For
context, a lot of self-driving uh
initially seemed really fast but was
really slow in progress because it was
sort of the same issues. So everybody in
the space from 2017 to 2020 was really
focused on perception models and
thinking that all you really needed to
do was uh take the state of the world
and make boxes and then you can drive
around the boxes really easily. It turns
out that assumption wasn't necessarily
true and there's a lot of hidden
complexity in creating action models and
not just predictive models. Similarly in
language models we can see that we can
understand basically everything about
the world that comes in via text. We can
generate really long sophisticated
reasoning traces.
But when you take these really
sophisticated plans, really
sophisticated chains of tool calls and
you implement them in the real world,
you can see things go wrong all the
time. You can see the tool calls fail
and the agent failed to progress. You
can see the agent failed to correct from
its own mistakes. This is sort of the
loop that is deceptively tricky about
when you get into actions from
predictive models. This is really where
the bulk of the work had been and where
a bulk of the work will continue to be
in agents as well.
I also want to point out in both of
these cases in self-driving when it
comes to robotics
and in code when it comes to digital
agents we're actually very lucky in
both. Like why are we lucky? I you can
see self-driving working really well in
production today in limited cases
whereas the rest of robotics is still
limited to demos and this is because of
how we have this machine that's
predefined with human controls that's
been really well refined over the last
few decades and then it has electronic
controls and it has built-in telemetry
right so it's something that you already
have a predefined interface to take
actions with and you have predefined
interfaces to collect the data from.
So that makes it really convenient to
operate through code and it makes it
really convenient to perform machine
learning and learning in general on. We
have this predefined interface with
predefined actions and predefined
telemetry and that makes it much much
easier of a task than going into some of
these other knowledge work tasks that
require the full desktop and things that
are less easy to codify.
So when we explore new domains, these
are some of the things we want to
consider. Is there somewhere where we
already get a predefined human interface
that makes it easy to do those two
things?
Finally, I want to talk about one of the
things that we face from day-to-day and
that's the hill climbing process. And if
you're not familiar with hill climbing,
it's basically this iterative process of
building or iterating on a complex
system such as an LM or an agent. when
you don't always make forward progress.
So before when we were working on full
stack web applications or working on
more simple systems, you implement a
feature and you probably guarantee that
feature will arrive into prod. Nowadays
you have this sort of like nebulous
metric that you're trying to hit. And
the only way you can do that is by
guessing and checking. So you have a
metric like a benchmark, then you make
some guess, you run some experiment and
you hope you go up, sometimes you go
down, but as long as you keep going up
and up and up, then you can eventually
reach your goal. And that's the concept
of hill climbing. But how we do it in
the self-driving way is a little bit
more sophisticated. We actually start by
learning and then going through
simulation. Simulation helps you deploy
with confidence and it also helps your
learning. But then once you deploy, you
can actually get logs from the real
world that feed back into your
simulation engine. That's really
important because you want to ground
your simulation on something. And so you
start to get this full loop. The logs
actually become a much more important
part of the process than they are today.
you can get a lot more insights than
just your numbers, right? So like a 70%
at a benchmark will tell you a little
bit, but if you start to break them down
into different categories, different
cities, different ways you can mess up,
start to triage the individual failures,
you can get a lot more insights about
how to improve your system and on where
to improve. And that's a lot of what
we've developed our tooling around and a
lot of what we've developed our
processes around that help some of our
customers with their hill climbing.
Finally, like you know, we're only part
of the way there. At least this is a
metric from the remote labor benchmark.
And you know, I'd like to compare this
to where self-driving was back in the
beginning. And it's because we have
really great demos and we have really
great predictive models, but we're not
nearly there as far as endto-end work
completion. A lot of the reasons are
because of the things I brought up
before with actions having consequences
and the complexity of the real world. To
recap, we've covered the parallels
between robotics and agents. Some of
those are having to do closed loop
systems, getting closed loop feedback,
how we discretize systems, how we pick
action and input spaces, how we can go
from stateless to stateful, how we're
going from predictive models to action
models, how we utilize simulation in
deployment and in training, um, and how
infrastructure is really important to
the entire development process. If
you've gotten this far, I'd like to say
congrats and you've become a master in
this new topic that we're calling
agentics because why not? Because, you
know, robotics sounds cool. Why not make
the this agent development stuff just as
cool? Um because I think it takes a lot
of these core concepts and abstractions
to really make this go from something
that we hack on to something that has
dedicated real science and really
becomes a practice. And so if any of
these concepts are useful for you like a
lot of these things are pretty easy to
understand and read about. You can read
about openloop and closed loop control
MDPs fully versus partially observable
environments. You can read about dagger
uh offline RL is a really cool topic
that is featured in more recent robotics
work. And then just like the intro
reinforcement learning book is all
great. You probably will understand
these things natively because the
problems are really obvious and easier
to understand in agent space. And
finally, you can read up on a lot of the
recent robotics literature as well since
a lot of the field is converging. So you
can just start from the papers.
Just as a recap, you know, agents are
robots too. They act in the real world.
They make mistakes. They have to
recover. And all of these little things
really matter. Thanks. You can feel free
to get in touch. Here's my email,
jesseabund.ai.
Feel free to send me any thoughts or
feedback. Thanks.